>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Amy Argetsinger: Hello.
My name is Amy Argetsinger.
I'm an editor with the Style
Section of "The Washington Post."
And I'm here to introduce
Carl Hiaasen.
"The Washington Post"
is a charter sponsor
of the National Book
Festival, which would love
to have your support, too.
Inside your program
you can find a way
to give a donation if you'd like.
The Library of Congress has
been the festival's host
since it began 16 years ago.
We want to thank the co-chairman
of the festival, David Rubenstein,
and the many National Book Festival
sponsors who made this possible
to have this event in 2016.
There will be time for
questions after this talk.
Mind you, if you come forward
to speak, you will be filmed
for the library's archive.
So, it's your big chance.
A couple years ago the great wits of
the Internet started to have a lot
of fun with a certain trope
in our culture, Florida Man.
Somehow all the bizarre
crimes/misadventure sagas
that were making it into
the national news all seemed
to have the same protagonist:
Florida man arrested
for shuffleboard rage
attack at senior center.
Florida man jailed for golf cart
DUI at parent's retirement home.
Florida man suspected of stealing
naked Donald Trump statue.
And then, of course, his
sister, Florida woman surprised
to learn car she set on fire
doesn't belong to her ex-boyfriend.
As funny as this has all
been, the anthropologist
who actually deserves credit
for first discovering
Florida Man years before any
of this hit the Internet
is Carl Hiaasen.
A veteran journalist, he has
brought his sharp eye for the quirks
of Sunshine State denizens
and a sweeping understanding
of how things really
work there to a series
of hilarious best-selling
satirical thrillers.
"The New Yorker" once wrote that
Hiaasen has a forensic taste
for autopsying the ruin
of a once beautiful place.
He wants to find out exactly
who has made south Florida what it
is today, Newark with palm trees.
And so, in "Tourist Season" we have
a cell of eco-tourists who decide
that the only way to save Florida
is with a spate of violent killings
to scare off the tourists.
In "Strip Tease" the climax comes
in a plucky FBI secretary turned
stripper allures a corrupt
congressman into a sugar cane field
with a promise of a special dance.
And in "Skinny Dip" the
action is set in motion
by a corrupt marine biologist
who has been doctoring the stats
on the Everglades health
for the sake
of the agri-business
polluters who pay him off.
When he tries to kill his wife
by throwing her overboard,
she survives, of course, by clinging
to a floating bale of marijuana.
But Hiaasen has also had a
knack for finding the humanity
and the poignancy in his somewhat
cracked and warped characters.
In "Lucky You" there is JoLayne
Lucks, his protagonist there, who,
as he wrote, played the same
number she'd played every Saturday
for five years: 17,
19, 22, 24, 27, 30.
The significance of her
lotto numbers was this:
Each represented an age at which
she had jettisoned a burdensome man.
And he goes on.
And in several very deft sentences
you have not just a portrait
of JoLayne, but of all
these men in her life.
And going up to at age 30,
JoLayne dumped Lawrence, a lawyer,
her one and only husband.
Lawrence had been notified of his
disbarment exactly one week after he
and JoLayne were married.
But she stuck with
him for almost a year.
JoLayne was fond of
Lawrence and wanted
to believe his earnest denials
regarding the multiple fraud
convictions that precipitated
his trouble with the Florida Bar.
While appealing his case,
Lawrence took a job as a toll taker
on the Beeline Expressway,
a plucky career realignment
that nearly won JoLayne's heart.
Then one night he was caught
making off with a 30-pound sack
of loose change, mostly
quarters and dimes.
Carl Hiaasen was raised in the
once rural outskirts of Ft.
Lauderdale and graduated from
the University of Florida.
He joined the "Miami
Herald" as a local reporter
and has spent the past
40 years there,
later becoming an investigative
reporter.
And he's now a columnist.
Since the 1980s he has
published 15 novels solo,
three others with William
Montalbano, five young adult novels,
two non-fiction books and three
collections of his "Herald" columns.
Two of his books have been made into
movies, including "Strip Tease,"
which I think we can all agree
should have been Burt Reynolds'
Oscar role.
And his new novel, of course, if
"Razor Girl" just out this month,
where the protagonist
is Merry Mansfield,
a con artist who makes a living
by intentionally rear-ending cars.
As it happens, there
was a real life story
that may have inspired
this a few years ago:
Florida woman causes crash
shaving bikini area while driving.
Readers, let me introduce the author
of "Florida Man," Carl Hiaasen.
[ Applause ]
>> Carl Hiaasen: Thank you.
I hadn't thought of that Burt
Reynolds scene for a while.
Now I'm going to be
sleeping with the lights on.
The -- welcome, first of all.
I bring greetings from Florida
where apparently we're going
to have some say in
the upcoming election.
We live in terror at least every
four years that we're going
to have any responsibility, any
influence at all over the election.
We feel, after the year 2000, we
feel lucky they even let us vote.
And we also live in mortal
fear of Russian hackers
because if you're a Russian
hacker and you're going
to hack any state's electoral
system, and you're looking at a map
of the United States,
where would you pick?
Florida. And we screwed it
up even without any hackers.
So, this -- I'll talk a
little bit about "Razor Girl."
Ann mentioned the opening
scene, which is unsettling,
but it was based on a real
accident that happened
down in the Florida Keys.
And this book is set in
the lower Florida Keys.
And it's a place I love.
I lived down in that
area for a while.
My oldest son was working
at the "Herald" at the time.
And wherever he worked he would
send me the sickest clippings he
could find.
And the sicker they were, the
faster they came into my email box.
And he knew where they
were going to end up.
But this one I mulled over a lot
because this accident happened,
this car full of innocent
tourists --
if there is such a thing
as innocent tourists --
was struck from behind by a
motorist traveling at high speed.
Nobody was hurt.
When the cops got there --
and Florida State troopers have
seen everything you can imagine.
There's nothing that
really shocks them.
But they were shocked when they
walked up to the car and they found
that this woman had crashed because
she was distracted because she was,
as we said in our family newspaper,
shaving her bikini
area while driving.
This is a whole -- you
think texting is a problem.
Now you've got a problem.
She had the razor in
her hand and everything.
And in real life, in the true story,
the cop of course said to her,
"What in the world are you doing?
Why are you doing this right now,
of all times to be doing this?"
And she says, "Well, I've
got a date in Key West.
I want to look good."
And he said, "Okay.
And who would that be in
the seat next to you?"
And she goes, "That's my husband."
So, it's just another
Florida romance, apparently.
I'm used to this sort of thing.
So that's how "Razor Girl" starts.
And except in my book it's not
an accident, it's a staged event.
Because we have another cottage
industry in south Florida.
You may have it here.
I don't know.
But we have people who just crash
into other people for a living.
They crash their cars into other
individuals for a living just
to get the insurance money, to
settle on the insurance thing.
I mean, it's a hell of a thing.
I mean, when you think about, they
have to be pretty good drivers.
They don't want to get really hurt.
They just want to be able to
wear a little cervical collar
and get a few bucks out of
State Farm or GEICO or whatever.
It's just -- it seems like
another normal occupation to us.
But I sort of combined all
that and launched the book.
In this book, "Razor Girl" is the
first time I think I've ever --
well I know -- the first time I've
ever brought back a main character
or protagonist from
a previous novel.
And that last novel I wrote for
grownups was called "Bad Monkey."
And there was a guy in
there who had been a cop,
a really good cop, down in the keys.
And he lost his badge because of
some personal problems that he had.
And there was an altercation
that took place in front
of 2,000 cruise ship
passengers debarking.
If you've ever been to Key
West, it was a bad place for him
to sort of lose his temper.
And he loses his detective badge.
And the sheriff feels kind of
rotten about it and says, "Look it,
I'll get you another job.
But from now on you're going
to be a health inspector.
(What we call roach patrol,
in Florida ) You're going
to be doing restaurant inspections."
And this is not a lateral
move for any police officer.
So, I've got Yancy, poor Yancy
throughout the whole course
of "Bad Monkey" he loses 30
pounds right away on this new job.
He cannot eat anything.
He's in the back of these kitchens.
And in Florida, I don't know if
it's like this in DC, but in Florida
because we still have what's
left of our public records law,
all restaurant inspections
are online.
You can look them up.
Now, there's an app you can
actually put on your phone.
Don't do this.
I'm begging you.
But you can put it on your phone and
if you're going out to eat at night,
you can type in the
restaurant you're going to.
And you can view the
last few inspections.
And the inspections in
Florida are extremely detailed
and meticulously drawn
up in terms of --
they assign a numerical quality.
For instance, they have
to count up the roaches
and the mouse droppings
and all this stuff.
So this is -- and by the
way, there is actually --
this has always mystified me,
because I did a little
bit of research.
The restaurant inspectors
in Florida,
they have separate categories for
dead roaches and live roaches.
Now, speaking as a diner, I
don't care if they're moving
or if they're not moving.
If they're in the key lime
custard, I'm not eating it.
It's just that simple.
But so, this is what I had
Yancy doing all the first novel.
And I felt bad at the end
of "Bad Monkey" in a way
because he hadn't gotten his
detective badge back yet.
He worked hard.
He saw the big crime, and he
still couldn't get his badge back.
And so I thought I've got to give
him another shot in "Razor Girl."
And so he's involved.
He's sort of the main -- because
he's swept up in this tornado
of a personality, the
woman who's driving the car
in the opening scene.
It all sort of bounces
around after that.
The guy she hits -- she hits the
wrong guy in the opening scene.
She's been hired to run into
a car and distract the driver,
which would be very distracting
to come on that scene.
But she has -- there were
two identical rental cars.
And she hit the wrong one.
And the guy she hits is a
Hollywood talent manager who's come
from California to babysit his
star client, who's promoting --
who's in Key West, Florida promoting
a reality show that he's doing.
And this reality show is sort of a
next generation of "Duck Dynasty,"
if you can even wrap
your head around that.
And it's called "Bayou Brethren."
[ Laughter ]
Yean. "Bayou Brethren."
And the star is a guy
named Buck Nance.
And he's gone to Key West to do
a little promotion for his show.
Now, he's not really a
redneck because we get,
especially in the South,
we're a little sensitive.
But rednecks exist everywhere.
Every state of the union --
they have them in Hawaii
you can find rednecks.
But we sort of get the burden of
sort of the redneck stereotype.
And Hollywood reinforces
this person.
And so they decided
-- they do this show.
They can't -- these guys, Buck and
his brothers are not from Louisiana.
They're not chicken
farmers from Louisiana.
They were a bad accordion
band in Wisconsin.
But they had the beard and the look.
And they said, "Do you want to
have your own reality show?"
And they said, "Sure."
So they brought in coaches,
you know, redneck coaches,
to sort of teach them how to
run an ATV and shoot a shotgun
and do whatever Hollywood perceives
rednecks are supposed to be doing.
You know, get the wine
out of the house.
Just beer and the heavy
stuff, the Jack Daniels.
You know, the whole thing.
And now it's a big hit show.
And Buck has gone to Key West.
And the guy, his babysitter,
his manager,
is not there because he's
gotten in this car accident.
So Buck is left alone in a bar
on the corner of Duvall Street,
I think, and Simonton,
somewhere down in that area.
And so he gets up and he starts
doing his redneck shtick,
which has evolved over the years
into some political commentary
and religious commentary
that he feels now qualified
to share with his fans.
Key West, he finds out, he
got some very bad intelligence
about Key West.
It's not a place where
you tell the kind
of jokes that Buck likes to tell.
He's appalled by the diversity
that he finds in Key West, Florida.
Because he figures it's the South,
and he's gone as far
south as you can go.
Yet, there's a rainbow coalition of
people who now want to strangle him.
And he's running through the
streets of Key West, frantically.
I'm trying to lead back to where
Yancy fits in in all of this.
He's running.
And he figures he's identifiable
because he's got this beard.
And so he's afraid for his life.
He runs into an open doorway.
It turns out to be the
kitchen of a restaurant.
And nobody's in the kitchen, but
there's a pair of herb scissors,
those little herb scissors,
sitting there.
And grabs it and begins
hacking furiously
at his own face, cutting
his beard off.
And it all falls into this vat
of quinoa that is right there.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. So, Buck finishes
his beard cutting and races
out into the night and disappears.
And finding him becomes
sort of the mystery.
But in the meantime, the owners of
the restaurant see what's happened.
And then Yancy, who's the main
restaurant inspector is at home,
minding his own business,
smoking a joint,
not doing -- and the phone rings.
And it's like a code red.
You've got to get to this --
you're not going to believe
what's happened to the quinoa.
You've got to get over here.
So, Yancy is then drawn
into the mystery.
And from there it rambles on.
I do want to say, I
always try to come up --
a lot of the stuff in
these novels, obviously,
I just poach from the headlines
or from real life in Florida.
And I try to ratchet
it up a notch or two.
And even more than that.
And you want it to endure.
If you're writing satire
you would like it to endure
at least a generation, you know,
before it actually
comes true in real life.
So, I had invented Buck Nance
and his whole redneck world.
And in the book he comes face to
face with a real, honest to God,
south Florida redneck who emulates,
worships him, from the show.
And he's looking, he's sort
of looking at his own mirror,
into sort of the hateful
persona of someone he's created
by the things he said on his show.
And there's a moment
of revelation there.
And I wrote all this before the
current election cycle started.
I mean, I was done -- I mean, I
was done probably in December,
maybe January with the
manuscript, I'm guessing.
And, you know, put it to bed.
Off it goes.
And then I turn on the Republican
National Convention in July,
out of Cleveland, Ohio
in the year 2016.
One of the kickoff speakers
is a "Duck Dynasty" dude.
[ Laughter ]
I'm totally pissed off
because I never dreamed
of having this character
that I invented address a
national political convention.
[ Laughter ]
Of, you know, all the crazy
stuff I have him doing,
my editor in New York would
have said, "What are you doing?
That'll never happen.
That's nuts.
You can't, you know,
that's slapstick.
That's not satire."
But that's where we are.
So, that's where we've evolved.
And now, as I said, we're --
you know, you look to Florida,
which is really truly -- the way
I've always looked at it, I was born
and raised down there, is if
something's going to go wrong
in the United States of America,
it's going to go wrong
in Florida first.
All of us in Florida feel this way.
We know. We understand that we
are on the cutting-edge of sort
of sleaze and depravity
and dysfunction.
And we're proud of it.
We're all in it together.
We get this.
We know. We cope.
The humor is what gets us
through the whole thing.
There's a scene in the book --
I wanted to give Yancy a
kind of a special adversary
in his day job on the roach patrol.
Because it gets old counting the
roach wings and rat droppings.
But there was a real
-- when I was living
down in the Keys there would
be stories in the paper.
They'd have these sightings
of an animal, a creature.
An exotic creature that had been
brought into the keys and let go.
And it was called a giant
Gambian pouched rat.
And for a writer like
me, it was music to my --
I mean, it was, this was where
I get my literary inspiration.
Not just a regular pouched rat,
but a giant Gambian pouched rat
that was brought in from
Senegal and Morocco and Gambia.
And there have been sightings
all throughout the Keys.
So I started doing some research
because I thought this is something
Yancy ought to come face to face
with in his travels is a
giant Gambian pouched rat.
And I made the mistake --
don't do this now, please --
but I made the mistake of
Googling giant Gambian pouched rat.
It's the largest species
of rat in the world.
It grows to about 9 pounds, okay?
And at some point in the '70s
somebody thought it would be a great
idea to start importing
them into the United States.
Because the American -- what the
American pet trade needed was a rat
that you needed to put on
a leash, it was so big.
And that people would
buy for their kids.
A rat they had to walk like a dog.
Shockingly, it didn't catch on.
And so, there were lots of people --
the Feds stepped in and
actually stopped the importation
of this gigantic rat.
And there was a fellow down in the
lower Keys had optimistically bought
a whole bunch of giant
Gambian pouched rats.
And bred them and had
them all there.
And then the word comes down
you can't sell them anymore.
It's over.
And so he did exactly what all
the python owners in Florida do
when the pets get too big,
is he just opened the cage
and he said, "Beat it, guys.
Hit the bricks."
And he let them all go.
And they've tried to
get rid of them.
There are not a lot of them.
There's not a galloping
infestation of these things.
I don't want to give
the wrong impression.
But for the purposes of
literary fiction like mine,
I didn't need a lot of them.
I just needed a couple.
I need a couple big-ass rats.
That's all I needed.
So, there's a scene -- and I think
I handled it pretty tastefully --
where Yancy is summoned to
this restaurant at night.
And the owners have --
the place is vacated.
All the diners, all the
customers have run away
because they've seen this
creature run through.
This is a restaurant in Key West.
They've seen this creature
running through the dining room.
The screaming and yelling,
they've run.
And of course, it's Key West, so
the owner is saying, "Wait, wait.
It's not what you think it is.
It's just one of Hemingway's cats.
They just got in the back door."
You know, the Hemingway has all
these 8-toed cats, you know?
And so nobody bought it.
It's already on Yelp and
TripAdvisor that there's, you know,
a rat the size of a
golden retriever running
through this frickin' restaurant.
So the owner's in a panic.
They call Yancy.
He shows up.
And all he's got handy for
a weapon is a pitchfork.
And the reason he's
got a pitchfork is --
and when you leave and you're
in the privacy, some safe place
and you Google and
you hit Google Images
of giant Gambian pouched rats,
one of the images that will pop
onto your screen and horrify you --
and I'm not going to give it away.
There's three elements
to the photograph
that you're going to be looking at.
There's going to be a man.
There's going to be a giant rat.
And there's going to be a pitchfork.
And I'll just leave it at that.
So, anyway, so Yancy's
got a pitchfork.
He goes into the restaurant.
It's dark.
It's a nice, very elegant
restaurant.
And there is a giant
Gambian pouched rat.
And a pursuit ensues.
And the rat, at one point, leaps
from this beautiful mahogany bar,
leaps in the air, and
dangles very briefly
from the framed Michelin award
that the restaurant has won the
previous year for gourmet dining.
And so, that's when I
say tastefully handled.
Because this is how it's
done if you're going to deal
with giant rats in a book.
And then the rat gets
away and it goes on.
And there's a lot of other really
disturbing stuff in the novel.
This is all kind of physical.
I mean, it's all kind
of psychotherapy for me.
Florida is a constant
fountain of, you know, now --
I have to say something about
zika mosquitos while we're here.
And we have this governor from
Mars who won't allow anyone
to use the word "climate change"
or "global warming"
or anything like that.
Anyway, if you've been
watching the news,
and then we're going
to take some questions.
His very first press conference
about the zika mosquitoes,
this neighborhood called
Wynwood in Miami, if you know it.
My granddaughter goes to school
in the neighborhood, so
I'm familiar with it.
Anyway, that's the first
outbreak is Wynwood.
But he holds a press conference
with a big map behind him.
And this is all about
the tourism, by the way.
This is all about not
scaring tourists away,
which is what I've been
trying to do for 30 years.
And failed miserably.
But anyway, there's Governor Scott.
And behind him is this graphic.
And the zone is all colored
in, the mosquito zone.
The zika zone.
And I'm looking at
him on the television.
And I noticed that it's
perfectly boundaried
by here's a highway,
like 54th street.
And it's all -- so
Dixie Highway, whatever.
That's where the mosquitos are.
Please don't worry.
It's all under control.
Because, after all, mosquitos
would never cross a highway.
What have they got?
The National Guard
with like fly swatters?
They're mosquitoes, for God's sakes.
They go wherever they want to.
But it was just the
perfect Florida moment
where he's saying,
"Don't worry folks.
This is the only place they're at.
And we've got them all cornered.
All six billion of
the little things."
And the other thing that was great
is they have mosquito trappers
in Florida.
Mosquito -- that's
like a job in Florida.
Mosquito trapper.
And I always thought that whenever
they were trapping mosquitoes all
they did was put some big, sweaty
guy out, take his shirt off
and lay him out there
for about 15 minutes
and you've got all the
mosquitoes you could possibly.
But no, they've got
little tiny traps.
And they're collecting them.
And he said they tested -- tested --
over 150,000 mosquitoes,
which is nonsense.
I mean, but can you see, you
know, with the -- anyway.
It's so comical.
That's for another
book at another time.
It'll be there.
But anyway, I'm going to take as
many questions as they let me.
And then somebody's going
to bring a hook out.
So we can talk about
whatever you want to.
This book, or any of the
nonsense that's going on.
I know the rat story, this
is what usually works.
The rat story sends them
running for the back
of the -- I don't blame you.
They're going to go look
up the rat right now.
[ Laughter ]
I can repeat the question
if they don't want to --
if they don't want to do
the Steve Harvey thing.
I can do that.
You're just numb, aren't you?
Here comes some timid -- uh oh.
>> Hello. I was wondering
how your guitar is going?
>> Carl Hiaasen: My guitar playing?
>> Yes.
>> Carl Hiaasen: Oh, you've
gone right into the -- yeah.
No, I haven't touched
a guitar in 10 years.
I used to play with, occasionally,
with Dave Barry's band.
Where Stephen King also played.
And back -- the band that
I used to call Authors
who Own Musical Instruments.
But I was a terrible guitarist.
In fact, when I performed --
the Rock Bottom Remainders
was Dave's band when I was
with them a few times, the few
times that I was with them.
I actually had my guitar teacher
come on stage and stand next to me
and play and shout out the chords.
Because I couldn't tell what the
hell anyone else was playing.
That's a true story.
Dave thought it was pathetic.
It was pathetic.
But I was [inaudible] I
was going to get up there.
Yes. Hi.
>> Hi. So your books have
wonderfully absurd themes.
And I adore this.
But one of my favorite
things about them is
that you have the most
creative insults I've ever read.
And I am very curious
about your thought process
as you come up with some of those.
Very entertaining turns of phrase.
>> Carl Hiaasen: They're
not something we want
to repeat, necessarily.
But yeah. Oh, you mean
some of the profanity?
Or just the general insult.
>> There were a couple of terms
that were used to describe people
that were extremely creative.
>> Carl Hiaasen: There's
one term that I've used.
And most of the people
here are grownups,
so I'm going to say it anyway.
What are they going do to me?
I've already got the microphone.
That has been embraced
widely, and I don't know why.
It was a term -- I referred to
somebody as a shit weasel one time.
>> That was one of the [inaudible].
>> Carl Hiaasen: That
came, actually,
out of my mouth while I was
driving on I-95 in south Florida.
And it came out of my mouth
while my young son was
in the car at the time, I believe.
And he was so enthusiastic about it.
And he felt that I
had achieved something
that should be shared with readers.
But that's the kind of --
it's just out of my own head.
I don't have any -- it's
nothing literary about this.
It's just, I'm obviously
not a well person.
And these things happen.
I scream and yell a little bit.
And then sometimes
I write them down.
But thank you for asking.
Yes.
>> Right. Skink.
Was he patterned after a
particular governor of Florida?
All of them?
And have ever met a governor of
Florida and referred to Skink?
>> Carl Hiaasen: Yeah.
I mean, he wasn't --
Skink was this old,
and he's been in a
bunch of my novels.
And he at one time had
been a Vietnam War hero.
Come home.
Persuaded to run for governor.
He gets to Tallahassee, discovers
he's like the only honest human
in the entire area code of
that part of the panhandle.
He goes crazy one day,
rips off his clothes,
runs into the woods
and lives on road kill.
All seemed like a normal
reaction to Tallahassee.
If you've ever been
there, and I can tell you.
But he wasn't modeled --
to answer your question,
he wasn't modeled on
any real governor.
But I know of a couple former
governors who would tell people --
and I met a couple of them -- but
who would tell people that they --
that I modeled Skink on
them, which was so bizarre.
I mean, they were so detached
from reality, these guys.
No. It was one of those
characters you invent
because you wish there
had been someone like him.
Florida would be better
off if there were.
And there is to this day people
who print up bumper stickers
down there saying "Reelect Skink."
And they send me pictures of it.
So that's pretty cool.
>> And I think you've
answered this question.
Could you have set your books, say,
like Indiana or some other state?
It's got to be Florida.
>> Carl Hiaasen: They certainly
have weirdness in every state.
I do get the correspondence.
But I don't think they have -- I
refer to Florida as this great,
wonderful fountain of sleaze.
And I also because I was
born and raised there,
I don't know that I would
bring the same perspective,
or the same anger to it.
Because that's basically
where humor comes from is --
the best humor comes from
being pissed off in a deep part
of yourself about what's happening.
Outrage. Injustice.
All that stuff.
I don't know if I feel
that way about any place
that I felt about Florida.
But thanks for the question.
>> Thank you.
And I love your books
>> Carl Hiaasen: Thanks.
Thank you so much.
Yes, ma'am.
>> I was wondering what
is the favorite book
that you've read and why?
>> Carl Hiaasen: Oh, I
mean, I get asked this.
I can't think of a single
favorite book that I've read.
I think that -- as books
that influenced me a lot.
I've told -- it was a very -- one of
the many, but a there was a writer,
we had a great writer in north
Florida, name was Harry Crews.
And he was out of his mind crazy.
And he taught at the
University of Florida.
And he wrote several
highly acclaimed novels.
But one of which didn't get a lot
of attention was called "Car."
And it was about a guy who eats and
entire Ford Maverick at a dealership
in Jacksonville from
bumper to bumper.
They cube up with blowtorches.
And it's a promotion,
you know, to sell cars.
And they've got the guy on
stage on a commode, basically,
for the whole length of
the -- it's phenomenal.
It's one of the funniest
books I ever read in my life.
And I thought: he got
this published.
He actually got this published.
There's hope.
There's hope for me.
But Harry Crews.
He was great.
And then I think Joseph Heller
had a big influence on me.
"Catch-22" certainly did.
Because satire is a tough thing.
It really -- you're
walking this tight rope.
You want the suspense.
You want a story.
You want characters
people care about.
You also have to have them
laughing on every page.
So, if you're off by a single
beat or a measure or a rhythm,
if that makes sense, in your
sentences or in a paragraph
or in a scene that you're
writing, it's not funny.
And readers know right
away when it's not funny.
So you agonize over that stuff.
Dialog becomes torture
because you're not doing it
just to advance the plot.
You've got your own little seditious
agenda as a writer of satire
that you're trying to
sustain throughout it.
So, yeah. I mean, it's -- you know,
there were not a lot of people
who do it is what I'm saying.
So, it's not like you
look around for a model.
And there's certainly not
a lot of people writing
about giant Gambian pouched rats.
So, I pretty much carve out
territory just for myself.
Just for my own sick little world.
Yes. Hi.
>> I've read all of
your young adult books.
And I was wondering if there's
a certain event in your life
that inspired your love of nature.
>> Carl Hiaasen: That's
a good question.
The young adult books, yeah,
they all kind of have that theme.
Well, the first one I
did, I can tell you,
was "Hoot," I did several years ago.
And that was like just like a
page out of my own childhood.
It was about this story of
these little burrowing owls.
They live in the ground.
They burrow underground.
And I had them when I was a kid.
There was a bunch of them
that lived near my house
where my mom and dad lived.
And one day a bunch of
bulldozers showed up.
They were going to -- they were
going to put up a condominium.
This is classic Florida.
A condominium in Florida
called Hawaiian Gardens.
[ Laughter ]
And the signs were everywhere.
And they had an actress, your
great grandmother might remember.
Her name was Eve Arden.
And she endorsed it.
What was she doing there, anyway?
I don't know.
But they were selling
off the condos.
And they're getting ready
to clear all this land.
And my friends and I --
and we were about your age.
Every day we'd ride our bike
past the owls and they'd all be
out on their little burrows.
And their babies would be out there.
And we say, well they'd never do
anything with those owls there.
They'd never hurt those owls.
And they buried them alive.
Even at your age, I was highly upset
by that, that that could happen.
It was so wrong.
And so -- I mean, I
was pretty young.
But all around me concrete
was filling
in these place that I cared about.
I lived out on the
edge of the Everglades.
And so yeah, so that
experience stayed with me.
But when I decided to write this
book, when they asked me to do
"Hoot" I decided that
since it's my book,
it's going to have a happier ending.
And that's the great selfish thing
about writing is that
they're my books.
And they're going to
turn out the way I want.
And something really terrible is
going to happen to the bad guys.
Really bad.
And I spend a lot of time
thinking up how to get rid of them.
And I feel really good when I do.
But thank you for asking.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> One of my friends on the
Internet has described Florida
as being the only place
where you have to drive
to north to get to the south.
I'm wondering if you'd
care to elaborate on that.
>> Carl Hiaasen: It's true.
I mean, Florida -- people have
often said it could be three
separate states.
South Florida would be,
because of the Caribbean
and South American
influence, would be one state.
The central part, because
of Orlando and Disney
and sort of the I-4 corridor.
And then the panhandle, which
is really just southern Alabama
and Mississippi and Georgia.
And it's very three
distinct demographics.
If you know, if you're going
to hold a Donald Trump rally
would be much more well attended
in Pensacola than it would be, for
instance, in Key West, Florida.
Or at least it would be a more
tranquil event in Pensacola.
Yes, it's a very interesting place
to be a journalist and a novelist
because it's so different,
so diverse.
We have 20 million people there now.
We surpassed New York in population.
Now, about half of those
people came from New York.
But, and our governor's
very proud of how crowded
and congested we are right now.
He wants us to be number one.
So, anyway.
Yeah. I mean, it's just
-- it's just a great --
I mean, it's a great
trove if you're a writer.
It's such an incredibly different --
you can in two hours literally feel
like you've, you know, you're in
a whole other part of the world.
And you might well be.
Yes. Thanks.
Hi.
>> I had the joy of
discovering your writings from
"Naked Came the Manatee."
>> Carl Hiaasen: Oh, God.
Oh God. Every -- who
put you up to this?
All right.
>> It's the honest truth.
I'm just curious how you
became part of that project.
And what was it like to write
characters in a plot line
and then turn it over and not have
any control over how it came out?
>> Carl Hiaasen: This
was a book that a
"Herald" editor name Tom
Schoder thought of doing
where we have 13 different
writers write a chapter
and then throw it all
together as a novel.
Nobody knew what anyone
else was doing.
But Dave Barry was smart enough
to take the first chapter.
And then I was stupid enough
to take the last chapter
where I was actually supposed
to read the other 12 chapters
and try to make sense out of it.
I'll just tell you briefly.
When I got the chapters, they had
literally three different severed
heads of Fidel Castro.
Not just one.
I had to explain three
different dead Castros.
It was a cluster, okay?
Let me just leave that.
It was what in Florida we would
call a goat wedding, okay?
And Elmore Leonard,
God rest his soul.
One of my heroes.
He had chapter 12.
I had chapter 13.
And I got nothing from Leonard.
And I'm on deadline.
We were serializing it
in the newspaper first.
And I'm on deadline to write.
I don't know what he's writing.
I call him up.
I said, "You've got
to send me something.
I've got to start to writing."
He goes, "Oh, God.
I forgot about this.
All right.
I'll get to it."
And like a week later I get a
phone call saying, "Okay, Carl.
Here's the deal.
I left you two dead bodies.
They don't have a name.
They could be anybody you want.
Two dead bodies."
And I said, "Dutch, I need
like six dead bodies."
I said, "If you had read what
I just got through reading,
you would know how many dead bodies
I need to get out of this plot."
But he left me the two.
And then I just did my best.
But that's -- so anyway.
Flash forward.
Me, Dave Barry and
Elmore Leonard are
on the Today Show sitting
on the couch.
They've somehow decided
to make this a book.
And we've mysteriously agreed
to go out and promote it.
We're sitting there.
I think it was Katie Couric.
And she says, "This looks"
-- she's holding up the book.
She goes, "This looks
like so much fun.
Would any of you ever entertain
any thoughts of doing it again?"
Unprompted, unrehearsed, all three
of us looked at her and go, "No!"
Boom. That's a true story.
>> Sir, in any of your
books, is there a character
that you would dislike
or hate the most?
>> Carl Hiaasen: Who's
the most hated character?
Boy, there was a book I
did called "Sick Puppy."
And it was about a lobbyist.
I know you guys don't know
anything about that here.
>> I read that.
>> Carl Hiaasen: Yeah.
And you did read it?
How old were you when you read it?
Where is your mom and
dad, by the way?
Hold on a second.
How old were you when
you read that book?
>> About 14.
It was eighth grade.
>> Carl Hiaasen: Okay.
All right.
Anyway, you read the book.
That's good.
The guy's name was Palmer Stoat.
You remember.
And he was, in my mind,
the world's worst --
embodied the worst of the worst
of the lobbyists that I knew
and had written about
and covered in Florida.
And I thought this guy is the most,
maybe the most despicable
human I'd ever thought of.
And I -- but then after the book
comes out, I had lobbyists --
I [inaudible] to them sometimes.
And they loved the book.
They loved the book.
It's the damnedest thing.
And they would say, "You
really nailed that guy."
And they thought -- they always
thought it was their competition I
was writing.
They never saw themselves in it.
But he was pretty bad.
And something really bad
happened to him at the end.
I won't give it away, but I
didn't like him at all, very much.
Each book has somebody that I
really don't like very much.
And I can't help myself.
But referring to Elmore
Leonard again.
And he always used to
talk to writers groups.
And then he would always tell
them, and we always know it's true.
The bad guys are much more fun
to write than the good guys are.
You can have much more
fun with them.
I mean, your own personal code.
Your own -- everything
goes out the window.
And you can just go nuts
and have fun with them.
And then dispense with them
as you see fit at the end.
So, that's another secret.
But thank you for mentioning that.
Thanks. Hi.
>> Just a point of information.
There's a place in New Jersey where
there is a mosquito administration.
>> Carl Hiaasen: [Laughs] Yeah!
>> I kid you not.
Every time we go to
Cape May we pass this.
And we say, "Jeez, I wonder how
they're administering them."
>> Carl Hiaasen: In Florida it's
the Mosquito Control Districts are a
political entity.
You actually have to go out and vote
for your Mosquito Control District
Commissioners, based on what?
What qualifies you, I don't know.
How much Benadryl you've
got in the house?
I don't know.
But it's that -- and in the Keys,
traditionally, it was where --
now, I'm saying traditionally --
it was where the deadbeat relatives
of politicians who couldn't get
work anywhere else would get
on a Mosquito Control District.
And they got a big salary.
And they were in charge
of calling the planes.
You know, we've carpet bombed
pesticides in the Keys.
I mean literally.
You can't believe.
And they're flying under 500 feet,
dropping chemicals on your head.
All to kill this little
tiny bug because it is kind
of bad for tourism, you see.
So, but anyway.
In Florida, it's an
actual elected position.
But it's, you know, it's great.
>> We just have been
travelling and keeping track
of insane names of places as well.
You know, so we'll joke around
and say, "This is my husband
from Cucumber, West
Virginia" or whatever.
But my favorite, my favorite
YA book of yours is "Flush."
Because I think what's really
exceptionally nice about it is
that the kids tell the dad, well,
we understand why you did it.
But you did it wrong.
And then they proceed
to do it right.
>> Carl Hiaasen: Yeah.
Well that's what --
you know, I spent.
>> It's a fantastic book.
>> Carl Hiaasen: Yeah, I
mean, thank you so much.
But the think I was worried
about with the kid's books was
that -- first of all the danger.
You never want to write down to
kids, because they're always smarter
and sharper than a
lot of the grown-ups.
>> Which is why it's a good thing
inheriting all our problems.
>> Carl Hiaasen: Exactly.
They're going to be running the
planet, which is a good deal.
But you want them to -- the way
they get the books is the humor is
basically the same
in the kid's books.
It's just got the same irreverent
smart-ass hopeless attitude
in those books as I do.
But I realize that they
love it when you make fun --
kids love to read books where
you're making fun of the grown-ups.
And then I realized that's what
I've been doing for 40 years
in journalism in Florida
is making fun of grown-ups.
It was just a logical transition.
And they seem to dig it.
>> We saw a great interview with
you on "60 Minutes" or "20/20."
I forget. And one of my favorite
quotes from you is that if you want
to change people, and
you rationalize --
I mean, you talk rationally
with them,
they just harden their positions.
And if you make them look
really stupid, they do change.
Because they're embarrassed.
I thought that was wonderful.
>> Carl Hiaasen: They get it.
You get their attention --
humor is a very effective way,
at least in the newspaper
business and in novels.
But in the columns as well, humor
is an incredibly effective way.
You can get up on a soap box and
scream all you want at a politician.
But when you start
making fun of let's say,
the size of somebody's
fingers, for example, you know?
Then they react in a way.
But they -- they get it.
You know, the object I think,
when you have a target,
and satire always has a target.
And the columns I write
have a target.
And I've always said from the very
beginning, you want as many people
to think, "Oh, that's
what I've been thinking.
That's what I really -- I'm glad
someone else feels the way I do."
And that's the one good
part of the column.
And the other is you're really --
you really want to ruin the day of
the person you're writing about.
You really want to -- you
want to wreck their breakfast.
You want them choking
on their Cheerios.
You want them to say, "Oh, my God.
They're making fun
of me in the paper."
And then you want them to face
their kids when their kids say,
"Did you really vote for that?
Did you really do that?
Did you really take that money?
Did you really sell out to big
oil or big sugar, whatever it is?"
Let them tell their own family that
that's what they do for a living.
That's the job.
And they ought to be ashamed.
They out to be sick to their
stomachs, some of them.
And I love it when I hear
that I ruined their day.
It makes mine.
Yes, hi.
>> Are there any headlines
today that you'd like to turn
into stories in the future?
>> Carl Hiaasen: Oh, God.
Oh, today?
Naw. Nothing's going on.
This is a dull year, today.
No, I mean, we've got -- look it.
We've got a guy running for
president who basically, apparently,
had hair implants from
an orangutan's armpit.
And he has a chance of winning
in a state, by the way, Florida.
One of the most diverse
states there is.
And it's pretty close
down there now.
I mean, this is just
better you could --
and Tom Wolfe couldn't
have invented.
This is "Bonfire of the
Vanities" on Viagra.
That's what we're -- that's
what we're witnessing right now
in this country.
And then it's not much
better on the other side.
But, no. The headlines in
Florida, I'll give you one quickly.
A guy drives through a Wendy's
to buy -- Wendy's drive-through.
And he decides it would be a
great idea to put an alligator
in the drive through thing
so that the poor clerk who's
giving him the Wendy's,
now there's a live alligator
loose in the Wendy's.
I just love that.
I mean, that will not happen --
it doesn't' happen in Nebraska.
It doesn't happen in Minnesota.
It doesn't even happen
in California.
And the guy just is, "Oh, dude.
I was just trying to have some fun.
I guess it wasn't too
good an idea, you know?"
I mean, this live alligator
running around the Wendy's.
Those are cinematic sort of scenes
that you'd hope would
be in a book one day.
All right.
Listen, you all have been
wonderful and very brave
for sitting through this.
Now go Google the pouched rats.
I'll see you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.